when you have questions that you really
wonder how to address it's so important
that you can play we have people in our
lab playing trying out things and
suddenly they see something that is so
exciting
I think creativity is really important
for scientists we all accurately think
that if you want to be a scientist to
need to be really creative if you're
creative and art you have to be
extremely skilled before you are created
and it's the same with scientists you
have to be skilled in how to do science
before you are creative I find a key and
I think that is one very very good piece
of advice for every single person that's
trying to do whether that is scientific
research or just their career in general
you need to bring the child you have in
yourself the curiosity that you have in
yourself sometimes you think you don't
have the time and so you try to push
because you think that's the most
important thinking that moment is like
to get something in your hands like to
achieve something most peak as possible
if you relax you are more creative and
also include a lot of other cultures
different people sometimes what you were
looking for it's not in your lab it's in
another lab in another field and you're
looking for it and you're looking for it
in the wrong place in research you need
to have many different points of views
love science we need different cultures
we need men and women young and old and
we need to talk to each other to solve
these big questions it doesn't matter
what gender you are or race or anything
the fact is that if you have an idea you
have to follow
[Music]